der entschuldigung dass der kontakt
bisschen später kommt aber um das canada
city aber wenn wir mal ganz kurz hier
schauen die kaufkraft der partei das
video was ihr wahrscheinlich schon
gesehen habe da einen gesehen haben
sollten einfach die europa 2 90 braucht
nach 21 minuten zum hofladen und
deswegen naja wenn man sich dass
ausgerechnet er erkennt man dass ein
blog bei mir ca 150 minuten dauert
deswegen braucht also ein bisschen
wissen wieder online ist
aber ich hab mir grad etwas zu essen
bestellt und zwar vom chinesen meines
vertrauens fokussiert ich mir jedoch von
ihren meines vertrauens der mir das
niveau bei bringt geld erstehen zwei
gläser weil nachher noch komplett zu mir
kommen dann gucken wir super bowl
wenn du das siehst ich hasse dich und
deine stimme das auto teilweise recht
krank bin deswegen hoffe ich dass ihr
das akzeptieren dass das ganze wissen
später kommt hier hab ich jetzt mal
mikrofon wie ist das eigentlich hier das
dort eigentlich zack da seien wenig soll
das auch so sein
darum kann ich dagegen schlage er ist
jetzt egal da liegt youtube money ich
werde gleich einfach diesen kontakt
eigentlich gar kein machen wo ich dachte
damit kann wieder leute füße sagte der
banker wieder leute haben deswegen nehme
ich gleich darauf wie ich chinesisches
essen hessen mit dieser kamera dann aber
in diesem stativ sonst war's das
wir sind wieder während ich dann filmen
wie ich esse so freunde das festmahl ist
angerichtet
das ganze aus alle die jetzt hunger
haben
ich habe gleich kein mehr richtig geil
ich liebe das was mein wunsch ohne
karten und ohne zwiebeln dazu sowieso
sie sind live dabei
während ich das ganze hier oder khedira
so kacke karotten wie die anderen hier
zu hause darüber ein bisschen kann man
ja nicht so trocken ist
ganze kg das auf ihre mentalität immer
noch minecraft hoch noch fünf minuten
sind es und dann werde ich hier bei
jetzt vielleicht mal schön bei münchen
gucken und dabei einfach einen zeitraum
vermachen
während ich diese portion ps und ja
entschuldigung immer noch dass der
kontakt mega spontaner kacke ist aber
ich bin halt wenig einfach krank und ich
kann heute einfach nicht mehr
freunde wir sehen jetzt ich habe hier
den teller selbstverständlich alles
aufgegessen
deswegen mit morgen auf schönes wetter
und da oben sie mit in die kamera wie
das für mich die ganze klasse das hat
mich halt die ganze zeit gefilmt jetzt
habt ihr sondern sondern waffel sicht
mal halbwegs und da drin habe ich das
halt gefilmt meine finger
hier sind meine finger kamera sessions
ein bisschen jahr freunde mehr als sagen
entschuldigung kann ich nicht sagen
für diesen kontakt ich hoffe akzeptiert
trotzdem hier ist trotzdem cool findet
wenn die einfach so jeff auffallen so
bis den film dies das könnte auf meinem
zweiten vorbeigucken der erste gast eine
bewertung da ich habe letztens mal auch
schon gemacht wo ich einfach so durch
den wald gelaufen bin ob ihr so was mögt
wenn jetzt nicht mögt einfach daumen
runter
ganzi sich dass wir die
bewertungsfunktion und sonst würde ich
sagen euch noch einen schönen tag viel
spaß beim super bowl nach ja event ich
werde auf jeden fall beim super bowl ein
bisschen was film während wir den gucken
und das auf luca filme hochladen also
flughafen werden videos über videos
heute kommen und dann wird die sache